we saw on the clip there another
addition to the cast our good friend
Chris Hemsworth I think I've got a
picture of Chris Hemsworth I just at a
certain point I thought I have never
rooted for someone maybe to be just an
unbelievable jerk I just needed
something to be wrong with him and there
was nothing for view it must be annoying
because you got to think we're very
funny and here's this hunk he's
annoyingly funny
did you bring writers or something funny
like a guy that had to fight his way off
the playground his whole life and he had
to be funny so he didn't get his ass
kicked very strange and at one point he
started I don't know we were talking
about music we're playing something and
I said what song are you talking about
and he started singing and I did not
mean to but very it was deep and
guttural I was like you shut up sound
like a songbird just be quiet
I don't help people to shut up but I was
like I said can you sing and he's like
walking Carrie attuned I was like I'm
gonna pretend you're a terrible singer
so I know you're human I bet he doesn't
even have boogers boogers they taste
like corn flakes
crispy crispy like that to spend too
long now this is wrong you partly song
discussing someone on a show we were sad
when he left we he got a cake it was a
lot and he did get fat as he was eating
cake he got more chiseled Tanner but
weirdly I didn't have any cake and when
he wasn't even his but I had gained like
6
about halfway through I I noticed Donald
staring at my watch